left-hander mike miner on the mound for
the athletics as we mentioned in our
open he started game two of the double
header in seattle he starts game one in
this one and tried two pitch swinging a
miss good first inning for mike miner
with a couple of strikeouts he's come to
back when we return
and that one is lined toward left and
that'll be a base hit
so marcus simming opens up the bottom of
the first with a line single
miner with a nice play
athlete
i beat you to it dallas
[Applause]
how about the magic trick how about that
smile from the old dog
mike miner
seeger up the middle
how about that through the wickets for
the lefty
athlete alert
chris bassett jesus lizardo eat your
heart out yeah
oh my just spread the knees just enough
for the ball to swing through
swinging and a miss and a pitch that was
in the dirt so three strikeouts for
minor and we're going to the bottom of
the second no score
in the hole seeger can't get it either
can crawford and canna has a base hit to
open up the second
first pitch to olson smoke to right
field that's a base hit ken is going to
round second he's going to try for third
irwin's throw is just a little offline
kenna sliding in with
going first to third
shot to right gonna get down for a hit
into the corner
cannon takes a peek over his right
shoulder and he'll ease into second so
another
opportunity for the a's the fourth
straight inning they have had their lead
off man aboard
olson line drive base hit left field
bishop has it they're gonna hold up
cannon bishop gets it in quickly hits
his cutoff man so the aza first and
third nobody out
first pitch to davis
in the air
irvin settling underneath it cannon may
give it a shot here canis tagging he's
coming home here comes the throw to the
plate it's way up the line so it'll be a
sacrifice fly
and the ease grab a one-nothing lead
[Applause]
foul tip and enter strikeout number
seven and that's seven in a row retired
by mike miner bottom of the fifth coming
up
and how about mike miner
seven shutout innings against the
mariners in his last start up in seattle
and so far not only featuring a shutout
he's also featuring the glove the
leather
no walks seven strikeouts for this lefty
who the veteran on this staff
and he is proving it today with his
style of pitching using both sides of
the play with an outstanding breaking
ball
fastball
and in the sixth inning in a seven
inning game
solidly stroke deep left center field
long run lorianno base of the fence gets
it back in quickly and a leadoff double
for braden bishop big day
with a former husky
2-2 to jp
[Applause]
going to left field again base hit
bishop browning third going to score
easily bobbled out there by kanna got a
tie ball game at 1-1 and j.p crawford
taking advantage of the bobble by canna
he's in scoring position at second
and spog experts so the new pitcher
for the mariners casey sadler the first
pitch he throws is drilled down the
right field line by la stella listel is
going to round second he's going to try
for third he's got a shot to make it and
he does
and the ball hit him in the helmet
a head first slide la stella was safe
but the ball hit him right in the helmet
i wonder if it got him in the uh
not ear flap side
seems to be okay
3-1 from hendricks runner at third
second line drive base hit maris take
the lead 2-1
j.p crawford's accounted for both runs
today
three for four
afternoon three and two
dragon ball
left field
canna with the throw j.p scores and ty
france coming through with a big rbi and
the marylanders have a 3-1 lead in the
eighth
rbi number 11 as a mariner for ty france
and he drives this one deep to right and
there it
goes
kyle seeger with a two-run homer the
mariners extend the lead to five to one
here we go three and two
and he does
got to be a satisfying win for the
mariners and kendall graven to close it
out like this 5-1 big 8th inning mike
tasty win huh yeah kyle seeger with the
big home run that was good to see back
his next extra base hill will give him
500 in his career so nice career for
kyle as he continues to reach these
milestones